there's some great demilio sister memes
honestly I don't even blame them for
this somebody put this together and I
don't know why influencers keep doing
this where they lar as like minimum wage
workers I guess this was a Walmart
collab I guess they're in the Walmart
break area have a good day at work they
says and she said you too and they're
like huh us too we don't do this and now
they got oh they're here they are with
the chip and they're working it's so fun
work at
Walmart I love working at wart wart
happy snap wait I think it's there
they're in every video I think that's
their brand here was another one that of
them just like laring as minimum wage
employees I feel like this is a faux
paaw that so many creators have made by
now that I'm surprised they did it yeah
don't act poor that's it don't it's not
it's not nice when you work at Walmart
it's not cute and then you're like oh
I'm look at me I'm having so much fun
here you guys you guys get to do this
every day this is so much fun I'm so
jealous of you guys